professor on if you were to advise an
actor who is slated to play a police
officer that will be entering a fresh
crime scene what are some essentials
that actor should know some details that
really people only in law enforcement or
forensics would know about well the
first thing that the first rule of a
first responder which is what we call
the first officer on duty is
preservation of life they have to go in
and make sure if there's any bodies are
they alive and if they are the crime
scene be damned you have to preserve
their you do what you can to preserve
the life get the EMTs and get the
paramedics stuff like that unfortunately
it comes sometimes comes at the at the
the detriment of the crime scene of the
prayer of the preservation of the crime
scene that said once you've secured that
once you've once you've taken care of
that then you can preserve the crime
scene and by that I mean put up a
perimeter set up the yellow tape make
sure nobody comes in and out make sure
the press stays way way far away you
don't you don't want to allow people in
that don't belong there and one of the
rules that we have is kind of like Boy
Scouts pack it in pack it out you walk
in and you walk try is the best you can
to walk at backwards the same way you
came in people don't understand that and
don't get that because walking backwards
in front of a camera is not a good thing
but that's what we actually do with with
the first responder the second thing I
have to say is study your role intently
Ian McKellen who I met when I was just a
kid had told me that read your material
in depth before you start to anything
cuz i'd asked him about a Shakespearean
play and he says I never read the play I
just do the scene but you need to read
everything you're you're young so to the
neophyte or the are the young officer in
training i would say read books read
websites you don't have time to read
books read journal articles read
websites look look things up expose
yourself if there's going to be dead
bodies expose yourself to pictures of
dead
there's plenty of websites out there
that have things like that that's
basically what i would say in terms of
an emotional response would most
officers just keep their composure in
terms of like what if they see something
involving children or just something
that's very disturbing would most
officers probably just they'd still have
to remain non emotional yes okay yes you
have to keep your emotions in check
would be a good way to a good way to say
it you have to maintain integrity of the
scene and yourself at all times media
has ways of finding out what's going on
at a crime scene they have microphones
that can pick things up at three miles
you know whatever they have their ways
of finding that I know of an incident
that happened years ago where people
were eating doughnuts and laughing the
command post and they were setting
things up in trying to get it going and
the media picked up on it and they that
department got lambasted its that's not
something that's appropriate you have to
stay with dignity and respect one thing
I always teach my students is when
referring to a person that has passed
away they are decedent's they're not
corpses they are not dead guys they're
not bodies if they are decedent's that
is the best way to pay respect
yeah and is there a gender specific
terminology or no it's always decedent
and if it's we don't know who the person
is is it a Jane Doe or that's Jane Doe
John Doe is very very prevalent so Jane
Doe one Jane Doe to Jane Doe three
sometimes coroner's offices will label
them Jane Doe and the date things like
that so yes there's we would still call
gender gender nonspecific and call them
to Seaton's but yes we would call them
officially in a report until they've
been identified of course then you would
label them by their by their name and
generally you would say you know mr.
Roberts or whatever for you don't leak
names out into the press usually until
something's been really adjudicated
which means it's gone through all the
way through court and through trial
sometimes you don't release information
like that you you preserve the integrity
of the decedent in terms of approaching
the decedent let's suppose the officer
realizes okay we have someone that has
passed away how are they approaching the
body they have gloves on yes a hazmat
would be involved you have to be very
very careful when approaching a decedent
because you don't know if they have AIDS
or if they have other communicable
diseases STDs things like that so
wearing gloves wearing proper hazmat
materials they have disposable materials
from footies to head to the head to the
the head of everything in between and
they're like five dollars it's it's no
big deal they're disposable it is better
to be protected because you never in
this day and age you never know with
hepatitis C and other communicable
diseases like that that our highly
contagious are highly easily spread you
have to protect yourself so then let's
suppose they were protected to had
gloves maybe some
footies or whatever how would they touch
the the deceit let's suppose they wanted
to move him or maybe they wouldn't move
them what would happen would that only
be the EMTs or the coroner's office that
would move this Eden very good question
the coroner's office actually there's a
corner /a Me's office which is medical
examiner the coroner is the sometimes as
many times the sheriff corner the Orange
County Coroner is the is the Orange
County Sheriff NL in south of Los
Angeles but the medical examiner is the
squad that takes care of examining the
body and they will be the ones that come
in and move it and I don't say it move
them and take care of the examination
and you are not allowed you are allowed
to protect and preserve but you are not
allowed to remove or move you can pat
them down and look for a wallet for
identification stuff like that be very
very careful they may have a needle in
their pocket and even if you're wearing
gloves notion doesn't matter needles are
sharper than any glove you're wearing
unless you're wearing you know
industrial strength but the emmy is the
one that they will yell at you if if
you've touched the body moved it because
and as I teach in my courses you can see
if a body has been moved or has been
moved and it's very important I mean a
five minute of rolling it over could
change the different could be the
difference between knowing that it was
laying down or not now not knowing if it
was laying down or on its side or
whatnot and that can completely can
change the outcome of the investigation
so when this officer is going to this
crime scene where are they checking for
the pulse to see if they have a decedent
see if it is a crime scene yea though
well that's two things the best thing is
the the wrist of course or the carotid
artery which I free which side that's on
I
do that part and then as to if it's a
crime scene or not always just I don't
say pretend always assume that it's a
crime scene until proven otherwise that
is the best formula for invest for an
investigation you can always also
another thing with the perimeter that I
talked about with the yellow tape and
all that you can always push it out
further because you can always pull back
when you need to so you may start off
with having a perimeter that's five
blocks wide because you don't know where
the the killer may still be in the
neighborhood assuming there's a killer
of course but as you find out no it's
just located at the house then you can
pull things in or a lot of times we're
under a time constraint if you're on a
freeway say a freeway shooting happened
you close down the freeway people are
going to get ticked off you don't want
it closed any longer than you have to
you have to get in get it done right and
get out you have one chance that's one
of the most important rules of any
scientific investigation is you have one
chance to preserve it to document it to
collect it and particularly when it
comes to like a freeway you cannot go
back to the next day your prime scene
has been compromised at that point same
thing with a house not too bad you can
lock down you can say nobody can get in
here you know it's preserved in lighting
terms it's a hot set um things like that
is you can you can you can leave it as
it is professor on can we talk about
someone approaching a crime scene and
collecting fingerprint evidence
who would that person be and how would
they approach this evidence the person
that it would be is what we term a
criminalist they are the ones who are
they study criminalistics they are the
evidence collection team everything that
is collected not just fingerprints but
swabbing for blood semen saliva perfumes
can we can do sentence to these are done
by criminalist let me explain it quickly
if I may there's three types of forensic
scientists if you will there is the
front line which are the criminalists
they go out and collect and preserve
everything then there's the laboratory
criminalist that does runs the assays
and runs everything through the
equipment through the gas spectrometer
and through microscope microscopy
microscopes all that stuff that's the
lab technician the third level is the
scholar practitioner that writes the
algorithms if you will for I you know
that that the laboratory people would
use to say Armstrong 2013 states that
this is person is five foot six to five
foot nine because dot dot I myself am a
forensic practitioner I do research and
I teach and I hope to create out of my
research an algorithm one day but to
answer your question specifically it is
a criminalist that does all the work and
they are certified it is not an easy
topic to do to roll prints do you
because there's rolling live Prince
rolling prints off of a decedent rolling
prints off a decedent that's been in
water there's also they're all sorts of
techniques and ways of rolling a print
and that's just collecting prints from a
hand then there's also finding a print
which we call a latent print blatant
means hidden basically so there's
finding the prints and developing them
you know pressing things with the powder
and then the brush and all that stuff
there's so much to just a
a fingerprint or thumbprint or an ear
print or footprint we have ridges and
valleys all over the place and we have
oil all over the place and proteins and
you can get things off of this and
because this is for writers I'll give
you a trick a bloody fingerprint do you
you do the blood or do you develop the
print blood gives you DNA and and other
you know do they have SES and stuff like
and now with a human genome mapping god
knows what else they can find out from
it depending on how much how big the
sample is where is working with a
fingerprint get you in the office and
the fingerprint database is getting
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
but so is the DNA database what do you
do all you design so does that mean if
someone went to let's say live scan like
they were a teacher or notary mmm their
fingerprints would still be in this
database absolutely okay I'm in there
many times right many many many many
times and so if whoever this person was
that was at that step they would be able
to access sort of this big brother of
fingerprints well you have to be in law
enforcement nice to get into code oh hey
sorry I automated forensic indexing
forget the S so but its its remedy from
the FBI so what if somebody did a DIY
fingerprints with scotch tape does that
work I have you ever okay so that's all
oh yeah yeah I lose my kids do it I go
here go like this and they're like
because that's getting the I always say
when when doing a kneading print run
your hair your fingers through your hair
because then you get the protein and the
sweat and all that stuff on there and
then stick it you get a much better
print it develops better for you if you
will and the and the glue acts as a most
of what I'm looking for acts as a
developer so they the the nothing clue
but the the stickiness of the table what
actually he's if that's the we're much
more would act as a developer so if you
do this the sticky thing you're going to
find a really good print but getting
that dusted and
and into a database many many many many
many steps so what's what would a
MacGyver of fingerprints do let what are
some some DIY tips if we were going to
show that in script or an actor was
going to play that besides the scotch
tape what are some other little homemade
things they can do superglue fuming they
did it in beverly hills cop too for
those of you for that remember that
we're generally you have a tank because
you need the fumes superglue fuming you
have a heating element i use a coffee
mug soup heater and i put stuff into a
little metal what would I call it a
cupcake holder try to get aluminum if
you can smart and final drop pour a few
drops in place your suspect evidence
close to it turn on the heater cover it
it could be a terrarium it could be I
I'm just using a plastic box at home it
was a you know 396 at walmart is no big
deal about yay big just so it is a
chamber if you will turn the heat on and
then let the fumes do their thing takes
5-10 minutes unlike in the movies where
it takes 30 seconds but the process will
do it the the superglue for whatever
reason adheres to the proteins in the
fingerprint and you can do it on a
coca-cola bottle on on tin cans and
pretty much anything that's non-porous I
say non-porous because if it has holes
in it that you're going to have gaps in
your in your in your prints so that's
one one thing and that's the biggest one
is super glue fuming I do that in my in
my workshops let's see what else would I
have
footprints you can you can develop
footprints we have in forensics we have
knowns and unknowns and then and we can
compare those things we're always
looking for patterns that's what we do
in forensics everything is patterns does
this pattern match this pattern does
this fingerprint match this fingerprint
that i have on paper if it does you've
got a match and you can go okay this is
John Doe from you know will form in the
rogue's gallery find out where he is
locate them all you know book em danno
all that fun stuff but with the the
footprints we can look at the wear and
tear on the shoes or did they walk on
their soul that they walk on their arch
that doesn't help you with your with
with finding the person but it sure
helps with the victim ology or with a
profile of criminal profiling
particularly for novels and things like
that oh you know he had a limp and stuff
like that there bushy-haired man with
the limp from the fugitive but you can
actually compare you can tell this is
Nike this is adidas because they have
very distinct treads on the bottom of
the shoes so that's something you can do
at home just take it if you want grab a
an ink blotter and just go on the shoe
and put it on the linoleum or even a
piece of paper it's it's enough to get
the idea of how you can play with this
and this is something I would even tell
actors that we had mentioned in a
previous segment I would tell actors
play with this stuff if this is how you
do how you learn how you understand
things rather than just going ok I read
a script and they say do this to this
this is how you truly understand and
take it to heart so going back to that
theoretical you know set with the young
police officer actor they won't be the
ones actually collecting the prints they
would secure the crime scene they would
wait and then they would wait for this
criminologist to come criminalist
criminalist criminologist would be
somebody who studies crime so
criminalist would come and they would do
the dusting and they were ok great they
would not the police officer would not
do it themselves well as you set it up
as a first responder yes their job is to
maintain integrity of the scene
the Emmy would take care of the body and
the criminalists would take care of the
rest of it criminalists aren't even
allowed to touch the Emmy and get
fingerprints I think I love touch the
body they have to wait for the Emmy
before they can print to get prints off
of the decedent as well amy has massive
rain they have their own investigative
squads to the the enemy's office if you
read Patricia Cornwell novels she talks
very much about having a team and going
out and doing stuff like that professor
Ron in recent years there's been these
horrific stories about you know captives
people that have been stowed away in
someone's home for years from a
screenwriting aspect what would you have
this writer do if well some type of law
enforcement is approaching a situation
like that they've discovered maybe a tip
from a neighbor and it turns out there's
been a few people living in the basement
something to that nature something
really horrific yeah from I my
colleagues in law enforcement that I
understand is first off back up do not
go in by yourself do not go in with just
you and your partner make sure you have
not necessarily SWAT but depending on
how you know how hostile the person is
you want to approach the door with not
trepidation but you want to be careful
you don't want to tip them off you maybe
pretend that you're the dye t diaper man
well that's only one bud but you want to
you've got to get them to the door is
what I'm trying to get at you have to
get them to answer the door because
these are recluse people recluse and
reckless it's not something that you
want lives are on the line here so you
have to be very cautious and you have to
be very meticulous in your thinking try
to always know the answers before you
even ask
j'en type of thing where you will
anticipate okay scenarios that's what
cops do you you'll know if it's this
scenario we'll do this if it's this
scenario we'll do that if it's this with
it I mean you'll have as much recon as
you can about you know anybody know
where are the rooms in the house where
the escape routes stuff like that you
have people in the backyard you have
people in the front yard typical cop
stuff that you see I'm literally cops
that's show all the time but you want to
do it carefully so that you don't impede
on or the possibility or create the
possibility of escalated violence in
some of these cases it seems like there
was a woman harboring a husband
boyfriend who it seemed like everything
was fine from the outside and then you
find out that this person was an
accomplice by allowing that person to
get away with it so if there was let's
say the the sweet doting wife at the
door how would you have the officer
approached that I've heard a lot of
cases like this yeah shocked to find out
that generally from my understanding oh
and this is maybe more from the news
than from the front conversation is you
give them tells you kind of hint hint at
things and let them respond with their
eyes or you're reading their body
language to let to know because
generally with a female it's not the
female that is the perpetrator it is the
the male unit
but there's still an accomplice because
they've been well are they are they an
accomplice or are they a victim as well
that's the biggest thing that I would
interject particularly as a writer I
would think that they would most likely
be a victim that's been beaten down
trodden as well and not that they're
going to show scars on their face they
they may have burn marks on their arms
but you know don't touch the face as
they say I mean it's easier if you find
a beaten-up woman to go so go okay
domestic violence let me in now I'm a
cop if it's something that's a little
more covert a little more I don't say
cold but hidden you have you have to you
have to put yeah as with anything you
have to you have to tread lightly and
and and ask probing questions that might
get them out maybe say can you step out
on the you know on the porch please you
know I like or I like the idea as a
writer of you know maybe a traveling
book salesman if they even have them
anymore do they have them anymore i
don't know but somebody something that
you know you can you can you come out
and see this arm now actually i'm going
to twist this i believe it was ted bundy
would use a little dog and say can you
help me find my little dog maybe you can
use the the same philosophy of can you
come out and help me you know do
something maybe it's fine my little dog
um but this is law enforcement speaking
so that we you understand what's going
on and then be able to question them
away from the person because as soon as
she steps away you're going to draw out
the person is going to go what the f
what's going on why are you here what
are you doing and then you can cut them
if you're going to be that bold writers
choice professor on from a screenwriting
perspective does the writer gain more
authenticity writing about the situation
from the criminals perspective or law
enforcement perspective oh that's a good
one
I'm going to reach into my favorite book
Thomas Harris red dragon where he writes
a scene everything's going third person
first person whatever he's going along
for with it and then he switches a scene
out of nowhere that is written from you
know and there she's holding the gun and
shooting it and it's completely written
from it's about the character that
you've been following but he switches
the point of view that's a writer's job
is to make us look at things differently
that's one thing I try to do with with
when I when I teach forensics to is one
of my favorite scenes is not a crime
movie is dead poet society where he has
everybody stand up on the on the desk
and and look out and get at just a
completely different view of the
classroom here we're in a classroom so
change your point of view play with it
what works best for you you may want to
write your entire book from the point of
view of the criminal but you still have
to have her your resolution in your
denounced off at the end but that's
something that the Reuter writer has to
choose and I would I want to dictate
what to say but i would i would just
advise play with point of view it's a
very very very very powerful so the
point of view of a criminal how would
that be shown differently it would just
be within the actions within the mind i
mean it just seems like both are going
to be very methodical criminals are very
smart they're usually very intuitive you
know and there's a fine line sometimes
because both sides yes we won't go into
that topic but but would they still be
very meticulous in their actions or
would they need more sloppy and that's
why some are caught
oh my favorite topic organized vs.
disorganized offenders we have a word
for it our name a phrase organized would
be Ted Bundy very easily he just giving
a real example right man very bright man
uh he actually took his own not his own
life he took his you took his own life
hit control of his own courtroom yeah
and he defended himself the right before
he sentenced him the judge looked him
straight in the eye and said sir I would
love to have you practice in my
courtroom and it's something along the
lines of however you're sick disgusting
man and you're going to die it was a
very powerful moment um very powerful
but but back to he is an organized
offender things were very neat his crime
scenes were very clean there's very
little evidence many times his crime
scene was different than his dump site
the crime scene being where one murder
the murder actually happened would be
the crime scene or the scene of the
crime whereas a dump site would be where
you find the body in Silence of the
Lambs they were finding them in rivers
and lakes and things like that so that
was not the crime scene he didn't kill
him in the river he killed him elsewhere
and as we find out later he kills them
spoiler alert he kills them in there in
his basement and then disposes of the
bodies interesting the reason I love
that book so much and it is my favorite
book is a red dragon soundless atlanta's
is good too but he amalgamates Ted Bundy
theodore kaczynski which is the
Unabomber maybe not him amalgamates
about four or five traits of serial
killers Ed Gein with the skin that which
texas chainsaw massacre was taken from
taking way out of proportion of course
Zodiac killer the Zodiac killer yeah
which may have been Theodore Kaczynski
actually so if you don't know this this
is just just a tidbit the manifesto of
the zodiac killer the very last segment
they could not decipher but if you put
in theodore kaczynski it finished it
exactly wow did not know that yes it's I
studied weird things which is why I
which is why we're here can you give us
an example of a disorganized offender
professor on yes probably several andrew
cunanan who killed ultimately ended up
killing Johnny gianni versace hard to
say um he was actually a spree killer he
was not a serial killer a serial killer
will kill and have time off in between
kills a few weeks a month several months
several years like Andrew Ridgeway the
Green River serial killer pardon me if I
get the name wrong those are serial
killers andrew cunanan was a spree
killer he had no cooling-off period he
went from site to site to site killing
people he was from San Diego and gianni
versace was in florida and he killed
like 10 people in between he just kept
going and going and going now it may
have taken him two or three days to get
change locations but he never stopped so
why was he disorganized what were some
of the things that he left messy that
ultimately got the crime scenes his
suicide I everything everything about
him was disorganized he was maybe a
thrill seeker I mean I don't know much
about him himself but other than what I
saw in the news as it happened
um switch one switch to Richard Ramirez
The Night Stalker he was messy he would
go in and murder and cut up and maim I
heard he took out eyeballs put in occult
symbols all over the place not that he
was necessarily into that stuff or not
but you know they didn't try him for
that they tried him for murder and they
and he died in prison on that 52 I
believe so i just found that out yeah
recently yeah but the point being that
he was disorganized and that he didn't
care where he made his mess who he made
his mess with cleaning up his mess
crossing his tracks we knew where he
came from we know how he got in and we
knew how he got out access and egress is
the words we would use access getting in
egress getting out he was just a mess
who else can I think of Kenneth Bianchi
and Andrew camera the hillside
Stranglers they were cousins they were
not again dump sites they would kill
them and then dump them on the on the
sides of the road I think there's the
two or the 134 or something like that so
we're here in Southern California they
just dump them just dump their bodies
they didn't care we found traces of
carpet fibers which is one of the things
that led to their downfall if you will
because we're able to as we said earlier
match the carpet fibers to Vipers in
their trunk and stuff like that hair
things like that trace evidence is what
we call it so I consider anybody that
leaves anything not anything behind but
preponderance of stuff behind we have
one of the first principles of
criminalistics is low cards theory of
transference what you bring in you will
leave a little view and you will relieve
a little I bring a little of what you
have back we will have this carpet fiber
on our feet when we walk out it will
have stuff from our shoes and
and our skin cells that have shed hair
follicles we will be in this room not
necessarily forever hopefully they clean
eventually just kidding but there's the
it sits low cards theory is the the
founding principle of criminalistics is
that there's always a transference
there's always an exchange so you look
for that exchange and then you look for
the matches if someone was to write the
perfect crime what would mess up the
forensics person from that thing i
always say that's the number one
question I get is is what do you do and
i say lie and lie first you get a big
cast-iron tub you put a body in it and
you pour a lie over until it's dissolved
bodies will dissolve bone at all and
then if there's somebody says have you
seen Fred you go no haven't you lie so
lie and lie however when the
criminalists get there and they examine
the pipes and they go why is there so
much lie in the pipes they're going to
get on to you there's no perfect crime
no perfect crime we will find a way it
may take time but we will find a way and
as writers we will find it in
interesting ways is it easier to write a
script from a disorganized criminals
point of view versus it and organized
depends on the way you think it in your
in your audience I personally think it
would be more fun to write a
disorganized because I like evidence and
red herrings and you can do anything
with disorganized oh I found this like I
said earlier a bloody fingerprint what
do you do with that you know you can
play with that stuff but red herrings
ago well it could be this it could be
that and you get more of that which
makes I think a better read this is for
novels of course it makes a better read
if you've got something disorganized
because you can go anywhere with it and
you don't know where you're going with
it organized pretty linear pretty linear
so it depends on what you're shooting
for
professor Juan what would a forensic
photographer do upon entering a crime
scene document everything this is one of
my favorite topics first often I'm going
to have to look at you for this when you
have a camera you see on TV they hold it
straight ahead we don't do that in
forensics we hold the light off to the
side so it bounces this way angle of
incidence equals angle of reflection
I'll get out of your face now that's one
of the things that gets me I understand
it's it's you know if they flash bulb
lights off it's going to bounce holding
something sideways as not pointing
towards the camera I get that but in Rio
forensics we we bounce sideways
otherwise the light will just bounced
straight back angle of incidence equals
angle of reflection really but but
refraction um something else that i
would i would say about forensic
photographers that i was trained as is
shoot everything twice three times if
you can and that with digital you can if
you were originally if you remember
can't you know cameras carrying you know
35 pictures if you're going to film 10
10 rolls then shoot 15 you only get one
chance you only have so many some
limited amount of time to capture
everything and a good example the oj
trial there was a image that the
cameraman captured or the photographer
captured in the bathroom there were some
at the day of you know the actual crime
are the crime scene analysis there were
boxes of Swiss Army knives that were
like six inches long or something like
that they never saw those boxes own or
found those knives they only have the
pictures to go on so they couldn't move
any further but in the investigation it
came up they didn't go anywhere with it
in court I mean they try but they
couldn't go anywhere because all they
had were it was the image had he found
oh there's boxes of image of stuff you
have to look you can't just take
pictures and go okay
great what are you shooting what are you
taking images of so you have to look at
your surroundings your cataloguing the
entire thing now I don't mean take a
picture and write it down we have what's
rim for scales that we would put down so
that you can know okay you know here's
here's here's a ruler that so you can
know that this gun casing was three
inches long as compared to one that's
you know an inch and a half or something
like that so we have scales and you you
put them down you take your picture you
pick it up you go somewhere else let's
see what else what I do as a
photographer so document everything
document everything document everything
and you're not touching anything right
no because that's the medical examiner
no the medical examiner's for the body
the body okay they decedent the decedent
scuze me okay yes so but then this
forensic photographer is not touching
anything not moving anything it's
capturing images as they are at this
well it's a conundrum which could come
in handy variety if you find stuff
before the emmy gets there the medical
examiner take it your pictures document
everything then go through the house or
the crime scene again after the emmy has
removed the body and take pictures
because you may have to lift something
up there may be an inscription or
something there may be blood there may
be a bullet there may be something
hidden you know maybe it was an
organized offender and they have an mo
and they they're leaving their calling
card and you don't find it because you
didn't move things so yes you do want to
move things but not before the amy moves
the body that's only if there's a body
there's plenty of crimes you know
assault not assault by those humans
burglary breaking an entry home invasion
robberies all sorts of stuff were there
are no people involved and there's
plenty of crime breaking into a jewelry
store I remember when in Beverly Hills I
was trying to get down Wilshire and
you know they just document my friend
ended up documenting everything and they
were there all night documenting all the
jewelry because if they were missing a
piece the photographs would reveal with
that so what are some of the things that
a forensic photographer is taking
pictures of doorknobs forced entry yes
wait we look at potential prints I mean
we talked about a finger prints earlier
they can take pictures of the prints too
you don't have to just lift them in and
and get rid of them you can also take
pictures of particularly if you use the
fluorescence techniques you will use
lighting luminol I don't notice remain
with luminol but blood that has been
washed away so you think can be
developed because of the proteins left
behind in the in the safes and the wall
if there was blood blood spatter on the
wall and people washed it down peroxide
gets blood out very nicely but it leaves
the fatty deposits behind so you may
have washed it down but you can use
luminol to redevelop the walls take
pictures of it because luminol will
degrade over time and disappear of
course because it's it's just it makes
everything luminous we use various oh
okay here's one here's ago we use
various colors in UV lights alternating
light systems to develop different
pictures and be able to see things you
can see written hand written articles on
a piece of paper where they had written
on a piece of paper above it and the
paper is gone now using a different
light source and with the right colored
lens and you can also see him with with
goggles too and and the right light
source they have to be matched if you
will you know 100 micrograms and one
other micro grams equals read whatever
but you can make you can see these
things you can photograph all of this
stuff they did that in
and I can't remember us read right knee
I was red dragon again my favorite movie
sorry but they have great forensics in
that one when they're examining the
toilet paper from the crime scene and he
had blocked out blacked out I should say
the the address of a will Graham they
took they got everything squished down
and then use alternating light source to
make the pen that was underneath the
blackout come to the top if you will and
then take photographs of it and then
they had to put it back and get it back
in this in Hannibal Lecter's cell so I
mean that that's that's documented so
there's so many things that a good or
even a bad forensic photographer can do
but the biggest thing is document
everything but we have two tips and
techniques to do things I'll leave you
with this one I'm painting with white my
favorite technique you leave your camera
aperture open generally do do this with
two people you cover it and you say okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna light it up now they
uncover it and then you either shoot off
your flash or your strobe or you can
take one of those big Sun Sun lights and
literally paint with light and because
you're leaving the aperture open its and
we're talking like pitch black stuff you
can get a picture of a house which I've
done you can you can actually get a
picture of a house by painting with
light it's a fantastic technique I
highly look highly recommend that people
look into that professor Ron who would
come in and determine a decedent's age
their sex their ethnicity and their
stature me okay and that title is
forensic anthropologists okay that is
what i specialized in I have my masters
and my bachelor's in Physical
Anthropology age sex race in stature we
say race now we say ethnicity God how to
break it down the simplest way to do it
is we have algorithms
of we take measurements that's the
easiest way there's metric and
non-metric ways of determining age sex
race and stature I don't want to bore
you with all the details of this but if
there are a few people that you want to
be involved with for a few reasons
forensic anthropologists will tell you
exactly what you asked a forensic
archaeologist will help you dig up the
remains so that we can get to the lab
and the forensic anthropologist can do
what we do I'm a lab monkey I did my
work in in in UC Santa Cruz in the labs
oh that's where I got my my my feet wet
so to speak sometimes you will also hear
about forensic entomologists because we
can tell time of death which is another
story entirely in forensic entomologists
will get involved with the three of them
work very very closely together a
medical examiner may have a forensic or
will probably have a forensic examiner
I'm forensic anthropologist on call
maybe even on their team bones love
Kathy Reichs she's the best forensic
anthropologist in the world right now
she wrote and created bones based off of
her books we don't walk in and have
we're lucky if we have a corner a little
loan you know touch screens and and an
entire staff and all that stuff I mean
maybe in Canada but not not here in the
in the states it's not funded that much
and to tell you the truth we don't find
skeletonized remains that often we do
find them we do find them but we it's
more will find in various stages of
decomposition which we will take into
consideration as anthropologists we are
trained in anatomy and an osteology
which is bones but from a screenwriting
perspective would this all this
determining of the age
ethnicity happened in the coroner's
office where would this typical scenario
take place we can actually do this in
the in the very good question we can
actually do it anywhere is the is the
broad answer we can do it in the field
we have field measurement tape tapes we
have osteo metric boards we have for
stature you know if you find a whole
decedent as compared to fragments we
have you know not yard shakes but no
telescoping tell us telescoping poles
that can get some basic information in
the field so we can because when you're
trying to identify somebody the first
thing you need to know is how tall are
they what race are they what our
ethnicity are they white are they black
are they asian are they mixed we can
tell some of these things by looking at
the bones we can tell some of these
things by examining remains now one
thing that I always want to make clear
in my classes and I like to make clear
here is human remains are not what you
see on TV human remains will start
decomposing within a few hours and
within a day or two unrecognizable as
human being sometimes other than the
fact that they're bipedal when there's a
you know a head on top you don't see
that on TV they say oh this person's
been dead six days and they look they
look like roses they smell the the smell
the sickeningly sweet smell of human
putrefaction forensic anthropology so
that's something for writers to take
into consideration is maybe a strong
reaction maybe somebody throws up maybe
they throw up three or four times my
professor and I always agreed throw up
and then get in there and do it if you
have to there is no myth in mythbuster
here there is no stuff to put under your
nose like in again Silence of the Lambs
i did a decomposition study with a deer
once and i put vicks on my nose
you can smell everything because vics
clears your sinuses real good you think
the strong smell wood over do it now you
you smell you end up smelling more but
that's a tip that uh that a writer could
possibly use is you know trial and error
I walked into I was a realtor for a
while and walked into a house that was
on a caravan and all the agents became
sick because we were it was a probate
and so I experienced that and and
another time like a coroner sticker was
still on the door and they had it listed
things like that what are some of the
little signs that if some was supposed
to enter a property and the body had
been removed but things like that the
the corner sticker would there still be
tape would there be you know biohazard
on the door like what are some of the
rule things biohazard booties all over
the place footprints all over the place
as bodies decompose they will have
purged fluid which is I mean if you get
them within a you know a day or two they
still will they decompose they turn into
liquid basically that liquid can stain
the carpet it can it can stay it can it
can stay on the counter if it's not you
know hazmat hasn't come in and cleaned
it yet or even if they had particularly
carpet it'll go into the padding so
you'd have to replace all the carpet all
the carpeting particular if you want to
sell house my parents were real estate
agents I I feel for you what else can
you tell writers um yeah so there's
metric and non-metric variations i wish
i could show them to you right now but
non-metric is the fun ones we have a
rule of thumb you ever had sciatica run
from the back here back here from from
your lower back and then there's paint
all the way down to the back of your leg
not yet hopefully okay that's called
sciatica there's a sciatic nerve in the
human pelvis there is a sciatic notch
and we have something called a rule of
thumb if your thumb just kind of fits in
there it's a female I'm sorry it's a
male and if you can move it around it's
a female because the females pelvic
girdles
breads so the notch becomes wider it's
much more effective when i play with
Fred back here on the side but wait call
it that we call out the rule of thumb so
there's there's something that a writer
can play with there but there are
non-metric variations that you can look
up I highly recommend starting at the
University of Tennessee Knoxville
website therefore they're anthropology
that's where the body farm well one of
the body farms but there's there are
many of them but that's where the body
farms was started but start with their
anthropology department and they have
links and you can find all sorts of
stuff professor on what prompted your
interest in forensic anthropology was it
a TV show was it witnessing something at
a museum what started it was very simple
I wanted to be an anthropologist because
I love bones it's that simple I also
studied I asked a cross trained Enzo
archeology which is animal nor remains
so formal I love bones my license plate
says into bones so I went to school to
study bones when I got there I met my
professor who I ended up being her
research assistant and all that fun
stuff she was a forensic anthropologist
number 52 out of I think there's like 60
something now only the board certified
and she introduced me to the world of
forensic anthropology ok got it another
caveat for you forensic means of the
courts it just means that we're doing
things for the people by the people of
the people type of thing I was on the
forensics squad in college and that was
the Speech and Debate team so forensics
everybody goes are you into forensics
actually what you're really saying is
are you into science it's the Forensic
Sciences that is actually what we're
talking about here forensics is just the
moniker but that just means that you're
going to court for it there's forensic
nurses that will talk about rape kits
there's friends it can
accountants that will talk about double
books and stuff like that because that's
still illegal if anything if it's
illegal or a criminal or even the Civil
Act it could be considered forensics so
I'll get off my high horse on that one
have there been cases of information
remains blood samples where it's not of
a human origin and it's not of an animal
origin I don't know and we don't know
what it is I don't know I wish I knew
though because I've done a lot of
studies on Bigfoot and cryptids which
are which are Loch Ness monster
chupacabras things that people
scientists haven't seen yet so it's
considered not real but other people
will will swear no know why it exists I
would love to find some samples of that
a bones even I mean it because I I can
look at bones and tell you a lot about
them and say okay well this is this type
of or maybe its own marsupial or Musil
adore stuff but no I I personally
haven't run across anything that's
unexplainable yet but I'm a scientist
I'm not a skeptical of scientist I'm a
hopeful scientist what about light orbs
you know they say decedent sometimes
remains at a property oh yeah in a light
orb and then this is the decedent's
essence spirit you know for a for all
energy and matter and we don't really
actually cease there's parts of us
remain so how do you explain these light
orbs or maybe that's not part of what
you do but if you were to write it into
something remains that don't things that
are still in the atmosphere that you
can't explain whether they're human
animal but they're of some nature
there's there's some substance there I
don't want probably not explaining no no
it's a subject that I love actually I
love paranormal and things like that and
I always say I'm a scientist so take
this with a grain of salt if something
coalesce is out of nowhere goes a little
bit and then Kurt and then disappears it
still came from somewhere it still did
something I will not say that orbs don't
exist because I've seen them in film I'm
not saying that they weren't made up but
why not why not I've seen many many many
many many dead bodies I've only seen a
handful people pass away mostly family
members I've never experienced that
myself but I had experiences as a child
that had to do with lights and colors
and things like that that I can't
explain I do have a funny one though I
finally figured it out though I sleep
canna tonically sometimes I dream and I
incorporate what I see in my dream so i
think i'm watching ghosts walking around
the room and then when i wake up i find
out that i had been asleep with my eyes
open i just found that out a few years
ago my wife had had caught me so there
are scientific explanations for
everything as far as i am concerned if
there is no scientific explanation we
just don't know what the scientific
explanation is yet so in a script how
would someone determine that it's a big
question mark or is that in science
that's there there always has to be some
follow-up or law enforcement there has
to be some result from an action
maybe I can answer it this way there's
no such thing as a truth there's only
such thing as a fact and the fact is
only a fact until we've unproven it and
find something else that's I forget
there's a name I'm sure for it out after
somebody from Galileo's time or
something but if you is it we revolve
around the Sun we all say we know that
now but there was years ago where they
thought that there was sudden revolved
around us things changed then they found
a new fact we may find another fact that
turns out we revolve around something in
the Milky Way and you know the Sun is
just a secondary or tertiary thing we're
getting very off the topic in deep here
but I like this kind of stuff just just
wondering yeah I'm often asked today in
terms of findings that that you could
not determine what species what whether
it was human animal it was the line was
to blur I could tell human versus animal
that that person can okay that part's
easy animals though being as
archaeologists as well because I
consider myself a though archaeologists
animals are a little harder to to peg
but you if you've got a good field guide
it's much easier to narrow it down to
this is a moose or I mean you can go by
size too I mean I know what what body
parts they look like what the the
flanges look like which is the the
finger bones or the carpals or the
tarsals which are the leg bones and
stuff like that and they look completely
different in different animals and
that's how we identify them it's the
pattern that we look at so we can still
identify things professor on how would
someone show the tricking of a crime
scene the the coming in with false
evidence to confuse investigators
that's an interesting take there's it's
only evidence until determined that this
is not pertinent to the investigation
and one thing that we need to discuss
that that we haven't talked about yet is
as a criminalist you collect and you
collect and identify and preserve and
all that stuff but then you pass it on
to the detectives you don't go let's say
I won't i won't name names but there's a
certain show where they had police
powers and they were doing crime scene
investigations and they were collecting
evidence and yet they were telling the
perps that you're busted because i found
this that and the other that's not real
life criminalists collect they don't
carry guns maybe they do in some
jurisdictions I can't swear to that one
but they don't carry guns they don't
carry a badge well maybe badge to get on
on site that says crime scene
investigator but there they don't have
police powers as the word I'm getting
too even with the FBI and and sheriffs
and all that stuff there the
criminalists will take take and package
their goods and pass it on as i said to
the lab and then the lab will do its
research and probably kick out most of
this is pertinent are germane to our our
chests or not or ? therefore preserve it
anyway if that makes sense so then they
will pass that on to the investigator
and that's the one thing that we haven't
talked about we're talking about in
forensic science all a lot here which is
what I do but it's the police that
ultimately do everything I when I say
police say please I mean you no sheriff
or CHP or you know I no derogatory
towards anybody just police policing so
the detectives the police officers will
do the actual investigation and the hit
the beat and do the the backup
information if you find a fingerprint
they have to find the hand that matches
it they have to do that by going out
into the field and interviewing people
and talking to people and collecting
fingerprints and matching them but you
have to have a warrant to do that
I mean there's a whole male you of
police procedural and there's a great
books on that by even the writers store
there's one thanks call police police
procedure or procedural one of the two I
recommend anybody that wants to do any
of this though to read a lot
particularly if you're a writer if
you're an actor as we discussed before
you're going to do what the director in
the script tell you this comes down to
writing read up as much as you can as
best as you can there's plenty of
website to put a course like Wikipedia
as we say in education you can't cite
Wikipedia no offense you can't cite
Wikipedia because it's not peer-reviewed
so you want things that are by crc press
taylor Francis SL elsevier those are
some of the the the morn own forensic
book publishers I would look into those
I would look into websites Zeno's
forensics page was fantastic I don't
know if it exists or not anymore but
that one lists everything schools and
places to learn stuff take classes don't
be afraid to take a professional class
go to the California Institute up in
Sacramento and take a fingerprinting
class they have a whole degree program
in santa ana college here in Los Angeles
are actually orange county has a a
policing program sometimes you can get
into post-training police officer
standards training so even if you can't
get into them maybe you can get their
materials study how can someone tell the
time of death what would type let's
suppose it's a car fire you know
and and investigators are coming out to
an accident and there's a decedent in
the driver's seat it's been on fire
fires been extinguished what would be
how would they ask to me at the time of
death ok that one's there's some easy
questions and then hopefully some good
points that I can make out of this one
as I had mentioned earlier time of death
there's a scale a timeline of how the
body decomposes and skeleton izes and
mummified and things like that which
we're not talking about here car fire
time of death would be called perimortem
there's an ante-mortem period which is
when you're alive or before death
perimortem period which is around the
time of death and we would just say this
person you know died you know perimortem
from a car fire and then of course
there's anti mortem which is after death
those come in actually more in play if i
can get off the car fire for a second
those come more and play with you know
was this mark on the bone made
ante-mortem perimortem or post-mortem
because we can tell because the bone is
green when it's fresh or as if it's dry
it's get the marks will leave different
striations different different types of
marks I'm in osteolysis I go back and
forth as to the carbecue one of my
favorite words that has to that you
would know within you know within a half
an hour well then I guess you can
actually find that somebody that died
you know you can find the car fire three
days later if they were out in the world
woods that would go into the timeline of
death and decomposition that I've
mentioned before so that would play into
it and the charred remains would have to
be taken into consideration I don't know
of any algorithms for for considering
that but we would so go under the the
basic you know rigor mortis livor mortis
lividity
I think of the process the bloating
stuff like that and we can still tell
roughly how long it's been the longer
it's been and this is good for writing
the longer it's been the harder it is to
tell whereas we can say we you know
rigor mortis had set in so but rigor
mortis also sets out it sets in that
sets out it starts 12 14 hours in but
within a day or two it releases and goes
out I may have my numbers a little skew
I apologize but still there is a it
starts and then it stops so you can save
if they're in rigor mortis it's within
this time period and that would still
work with a car fire a car fire that
just happened on the side of the 10 101
freeway you're going to have a
respondent immediately so you're you
know you're probably have eyewitnesses
that you know this happened almost
instantaneously you will not be able to
I don't know if this is part of the
question you will not be able to
ascertain how long was the car fire or
anything like that you can tell if they
died before the car fire interesting
fact though if there's searing of the
lungs yet this is that autopsy if
they're sharing of the lungs they
breathed in the flames if there's no
searing than they weren't breathing when
they died so they may have passed away
from a heart attack car caught on fire
because it crashed and burned so you
know you can tell if they were alive or
not when when they hit the thing so
that's one way of incorporating that